I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
>> President Trump: DON'T
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I'M
JUST GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO YOU
TO GO WHEREVER YOU WANT WITH
THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING YOU'VE
HAD TO DEAL WITH YOUR INPUT
ENTIRE PRESIDENCY YOU HAVE AND
WERE LOUD AND SAYING IT WAS NOT
TRUE.
IT WAS A WITCH HUNT.
AND WE HAD FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS BACKING UP YOUR
CLAIM AND CULMINATING IN WHAT
YOU SAW YESTERDAY, SIR.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL THAT.
>> President Trump: WELL, I
THINK PEOPLE LEARNED A LOT
YESTERDAY, WATCHING A VERY POOR
PERFORMANCE AND WATCHING THINGS
THAT THEY COULDN'T BELIEVE WHEN
THEY SAW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
HOPEFULLY WE ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO FIND OUT HOW A THING
LIKE THIS STARTED.
IT WAS A DISGRACE TO OUR
COUNTRY, IT WAS A DISGRACE FROM
EVERY STANDPOINT AND I WOULD SAY
THAT MOST PEOPLE HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
ON TOP OF IT, HE WANTS THAT
PERFORMANCE, IT WAS SHOCKING.
WE WERE SAD.
>> Sean: HOW MUCH OF THAT DID
YOU WATCH, SIR?
>> President Trump: SAIA,
SEAN?
>> Sean: HOW MUCH OF THE
MUELLER TESTIMONY DID YOU
ACTUALLY WATCH?
>> President Trump: I WASN'T
GOING TO WATCH IT ALL AND THEN I
STARTED THINKING ABOUT IT AND
THEN I WATCHED A LITTLE BIT AT
THE VERY BEGINNING AND I
COULDN'T BELIEVE WHAT I WAS
HEARING.
I ENDED UP WATCHING MORE THAN I
WANTED TO.
AND THEN I WATCHED THE AFTERNOON
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, IT WAS SUCH A
BIG CRATER AT THE BEGINNING AND
I SAID, NOW I HAVE TO WATCH
SHIFTY SHIFT BECAUSE HE JUST
WENT THROUGH THREE HOURS AND NOW
HE HAS TO GO THROUGH SHIFTS AND
NOW I WAS GOING TO SAY THIS IS
GOING TO BE VERY INTERESTING.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT, ACTUALLY.
IT WAS SORT OF GOOD TELEVISION.
I COULDN'T WATCH IT ALL.
I HAD MEETINGS AND I WAS SAYING
FELLOWS, MAYBE WE COULD MOVE IT
TO ANOTHER TIME BUT I DIDN'T
WANT TO DO THAT.
BUT I GOT TO WATCH ENOUGH AND IT
WAS SHOCKING.
IT I THOUGHT THE REPUBLICANS
REPRESENTED THEMSELVES
BRILLIANTLY.
JOHN RATCLIFFE AND JIM JORDAN
AND, I MEAN, ALL OF THEM.
LOUIE GOHMERT.
I CAN MENTION 15 NAMES OR
HOWEVER MANY THEY HAVE THAT
SPOKE.
IT GOT FAIRLY CLOSE TO THAT
NUMBER, MAYBE IT WAS A LITTLE
BIT LESS THAN THAT BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT EVERYBODY
REPRESENTING THE REPUBLICANS I
THOUGHT WAS REALLY GOOD AND I
THOUGHT THE OTHER SIDE WAS
TYPICALLY BIASED BUT THEY WERE
STUCK WITH THE SITUATION THAT
THEY COULDN'T BELIEVE.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I JUST
MENTIONED, "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
NOT LONG AGO, ACTUALLY SAID THAT
THEY BELIEVED THAT, WELL, THE
DOSSIER, WHICH I WAS STUNNED
MUELLER DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
FUSION GPS, THE THINGS HE DIDN'T
KNOW SHOCKING, DIDN'T KNOW CLINT
AND RAY, BUT WE WILL PUT THAT
ASIDE BUT THEY SUGGESTED THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STATS OF
THE DIRTY DOSSIER THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR THAT WAS USED TO SPY ON
YOUR CAMPAIGN, YOUR TRANSITION,
AND EVEN YOUR PRESIDENCY, SIR,
WAS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
NOW, IF THAT'S THE CASE, THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT THE RUSSIANS
KNEW THAT HILLARY WAS PAYING FOR
THOSE LIES, WHICH WOULD MEAN
THAT THE NARRATIVE THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FED BY
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS,
THAT, WELL, THEY WERE TRYING TO
HELP YOU, THE RUSSIANS, THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS RIGHT
FOR ONCE AND I SUSPECT THEY MAY
VERY WELL BE, THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO HURT YOU MORE THAN
HILLARY.
>> President Trump: WELL,
BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE JUST
BECAME FAIRLY RECENTLY, THE
NUMBER ONE OIL AND GAS PRODUCER
AND ENERGY PRODUCER IN THE
WORLD, BY FAR, RUSSIA,
SAUDI ARABIA, NOW SECOND AND
THIRD, BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE
NOW HAVE THE BEST --
WE WILL SOON HAVE THE MOST
MODERN MILITARY WE HAVE EVER HAD
WITH THE BEST EQUIPMENT, THE
BEST PLANS AND ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE, AND SO MANY
OTHER THINGS, SEAN, BASED ON ALL
OF THAT, THE LAST PERSON THEY
SHOULD WANT IS ME.
LET'S, I HAVE HEARD THE SAME
THING ABOUT THE FAKE DOSSIER.
I'VE HEARD IT CAME OUT OF
RUSSIA.
I THINK A LOT OF IT ALSO IS MADE
OUT.
IT WAS JUST MADE OUT UP LIKE YOU
WOULD WRITE A NOVEL BUT IT WAS A
FAKE AND IT WAS PAID FOR BY THE
DEMOCRATS AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC AND
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
THESE ARE INCREDIBLE STORIES.
NO ONE WOULD WRITE A NOVEL LIKE
THIS BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULDN'T
BELIEVE IT.
IT WOULDN'T BE BELIEVABLE.
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FM
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FU
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FL
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FY
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FH
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FV
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FE
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FA
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FK
>> YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, I FD
LINDSEY GRAHAM, HE REALLY, WHEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WAS BEFORE
HIS COMMITTEE, HE WENT THROUGH A
LIST OF THINGS, DO YOU FEEL THAT
MUELLER DID HIS JOB?
DO YOU THINK HE HAD THE
RESOURCES QUESTION WHY DO YOU
THINK HIS TEAM AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY?
YOU TURN OVER DOCUMENTS, YOU
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO TESTIFY
BEFORE CONGRESS, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, I WAS SHOCKED.
BUT I WILL PUT THAT ASIDE HERE.
AND YOU KEEP SAYING THAT YOU
THINK WE CAN'T LET THIS HAPPEN
AGAIN AND, I GUESS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT HE IS
GOING TO LOOK INTO WHETHER THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY'S
SERVER WAS RAGE, HE'S GOING TO
LOOK INTO POTENTIAL FISA ABUSE,
HE'S GOING TO LOOK INTO THE
ORIGINS OF THIS PRO, WE KNOW
THAT DURHAM HAS NOW INTERVIEWED
STEELE FOR NEARLY 16 HOURS, AND
WE KNOW THE IG IS VERY CLOSE TO
A PFIZER REPORT, WHAT DO YOU --
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE?
SPEAK UP BECAUSE THIS SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AGAIN.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE CATASTROPHE
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THIS WAS A FAKE WITCH HUNT AND
IT SHOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
THIS WAS TREASON, THIS WAS HIGH
CRIME.
THIS WAS EVERYTHING AS BAD A
DEFINITION AS YOU WANT TO COME
UP WITH, THIS SHOULD NEVER BE
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN TO OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
>> Sean: YOUR THOUGHTS --
YOU HAVE OFTEN SAID FAKE NEWS.
I CALLED THEM OUT ALSO ON THIS
PROGRAM.
IT TURNS OUT THERE'S BEEN, YOU
KNOW, I GIVE A LIST, STARTING
WITH RICHARD JEWELL AND
FERGUSON, MISSOURI, AND
CAMBRIDGE POLICE AND BALTIMORE,
MARYLAND, AND NICHOLAS SANDMANN.
BUT THEY WENT WITH EVERY SINGLE
LIVE.
EVERY CONSPIRACY THEORY, I DON'T
SEE THE MEDIA VERY OFTEN TALKING
ABOUT THE THINGS YOU HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED.
I MENTION THE EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION IS THE BEST SINCE
1969.
WHAT YOU SAY TO THE PRESS IN
THIS COUNTRY?
THE PRESS THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
FAIR, BALANCED, OBJECTIVE, DOWN
THE MIDDLE?
, TALK SHOW HOST.
UNLIKE THE WHOLE NEWSPAPER.
WE DO EVERYTHING.
>> President Trump: WELL, I
THINK THE PRESS HAS LOST ALL
CREDIBILITY.
WHAT MUCH OF IT.
BUT IT IS LOST A BIG PART OF IT,
VERY SUBSTANTIAL PART OF IT,
LOST ALL CREDIBILITY.
I WATCH AS PEOPLE SCREAM AT
THESE POOR DEMOCRATS, THE
CONGRESSMAN, SCREAM LIKE I'VE
NEVER SEEN.
YOU MUST DO THIS, YOU MUST DO
THAT, I MEAN, THESE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE JOURNALISTS, TALK SHOW
HOST, OF ALL SORTS OF PEOPLE, I
COULD NOT BELIEVE IT.
AND THEY ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
FORCE THEM TO DO WHAT THEY WANT,
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT
AND, YOU KNOW, AIN'T THEY USE
THE WORD UNHINGED, THEY ARE
UNHINGED VIA THE MEDIA HAS
BECOME TOTALLY UNHINGED.
THEY ARE VERY DISHONEST AND WHEN
I SAY ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE, WHEN
PEOPLE GIVE PURPOSELY FALL
STORIES AND WHEN THEY TRIED TO
GET POLITICIANS TO DO THINGS
THAT ARE WRONG AND THEY ARE NO
THEY ARE WRONG, THAT REALLY IS
THE ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
IT'S FAKE NEWS BUT IT'S THE
ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE, WARM
PORTLY.
>> Sean: IN OTHER WORDS, IF
YOU'RE CLAIMING TO BE FAIR,
BALANCED, OBJECTIVE, NOT IN THE
MIDDLE, AND YOU PURPOSELY WHY
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY INTEREST IN
THE TRUTH, YOU MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE TWO AND
I PRETTY SAY THAT MANY TIMES.
I'M INTERESTED IN THIS QUESTION
BECAUSE YOU ARE VERY CRITICAL OF
MUELLER HERE THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
WHETHER OR NOT YOU TOLD YOUR
COUNSEL TO FIRE HIM, AND YOU
HAVE THE AUTHORITY, QUOTING THAT
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, MANY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEYS,
UNDER MANY ARTICLES, YOU
COULD'VE FIRED MUELLER YOURSELF.
BUT MY QUESTION IS, NOW THAT YOU
SAW HOW LITTLE HE ACTUALLY KNEW,
DO YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION
OF HIM PUSH HER MIND TO DO AT
ANY POINT ALMOST FEEL SORRY FOR
HIM, DURING THIS?
>> President Trump: SO, HOW
THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO FIRE HIM
BUT I DIDN'T.
AND I NEVER SUGGESTED TO DO IT.
BUT I HAD THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
FIRE HIM UNDER ARTICLE TWO AND
PERHAPS FOR OTHER REASONS BUT, I
DIDN'T DO IT.
I DIDN'T DO ANY OF THE THINGS --
YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY SAID HE WAS
GOING TO DO THIS OR SAID HE WAS
GOING TO DO THAT, DIDN'T YOU
WITH ANY OF THAT AND IT'S REALLY
INCREDIBLE WHEN I HIT US.
THE WHOLE CONSTRUCT CONCEPT OF
ABSORPTION, WHEN THEY CREATE A
PHONY CRIME AND IS JUST A
TERRIBLE THING TO SAY ABOUT SOME
OF.
ESPECIALLY SOMEBODY THAT LOVES
THE COUNTRY IS MUCH AS I DO.
SO, THEY CREATE THIS PHONY CRIME
AND THEN THEY SAY HE OBSTRUCTED.
THEY SAID THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
BUT HE OBSTRUCTED.
AND THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS HAVE HER
BEFORE IN OUR COUNTRY.
THIS CRIME WAS --
THE CRIME WAS COMMITTED ON THE
OTHER SIDE AND WE WILL FIND OUT
ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVE A GREAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO IS LOOKING AT IT.
I'M INVOLVED IN THAT.
HE IS LOOKING AT IT AND, YOU
KNOW, I'VE BEEN HEARING A LOT OF
THE MEDIA ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT
INVESTIGATING THE INVESTIGATORS
AND A LOT MORE THAN THAT AND I
THINK THAT THINGS ARE --
I JUST SEE IT.
I FEEL IT.
I THINK A LOT OF GOOD IS GOING
TO COME OUT OF IT.
WE WENT THROUGH HELL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WENT THROUGH
HELL.
THEY CAME DOWN TO WASHINGTON
WANTING TO DO A PHENOMENAL JOB
FOR THE PEOPLE AND THEY GET
SERVED WITH PAPERS TO COME AND
TESTIFY AND GO BEFORE A GRAND
JURY'S AND BY THE WAY, NOTHING
AFFECTED THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
ALL OF THESE THINGS LIKE THE
RUSSIAN BLOGGERS, THEY HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH US.
AND EVERYBODY KNEW IT.
IN FACT, THERE IS A SENTENCE AND
THEY ARE SAYING THAT IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT IT WAS LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
24 VEHICLE OR SOMETHING.
A LOT OF BLOGGERS, BLOGGERS IN
RUSSIA, THEY WILL NEVER SEE
THESE PEOPLE.
THEY KNOW THAT.
THEY SENT OUT PAPERS TO THESE
PEOPLE AND THEY WILL NEVER SEE
THEM.
PEOPLE PROBABLY NEVER EVEN GOT
THE PAPERS.
BUT ALL OF THESE PEOPLE, NONE OF
THEM --
THEY WENT THROUGH PEOPLE WITH
OLD TAX CASES.
OLD CASES.
CASES THAT WERE NOT EVEN GOING
FORWARD AND COMMUNAL, WENT AFTER
THEM VICIOUSLY AND VIOLENTLY.
GENERAL FLYNN, WHO IS A GOOD MA
MAN, WHAT THEY DID TO
GENERAL FLYNN AND SO MANY
OTHERS, HOPE HICKS, THIS
WONDERFUL YOUNG WOMAN.
SHE SPENT MUCH OF HER TIME IN
WASHINGTON FIGHTING OFF THE
COMING YOU KNOW, HORRIBLE
STORIES AND THINGS AND SHE WAS
JUST A HIGH-QUALITY PERSON.
SO MANY.
I MEAN, I COULD NAME ALMOST
EVERYBODY.
WHAT THEY WENT THROUGH.
AND SO, TO THIS DAY, I MEAN, I
HEARD PEOPLE SAYING THAT --
I HEARD SOME OF THE MEDIA SAY
THAT THEY THOUGHT MUELLER
PERFORMED OKAY.
MEANING, THEY LET A DAY GO BY
AND THEN THEY WILL TRY TO SPIN
INTO.
THESE ARE VERY DISHONEST PEOPLE.
THESE ARE VERY BAD PEOPLE.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT, THE
POWER OF THE PARTY, ACTUALLY
THINK THE BEST PART YOU GAVE IS
ALEX MURRAY JOHNSON, THE HE
COMMUTED HER SENTENCE SHOULD BE
MORE ACCURATE.
IT'S ABSOLUTE.
HAVE YOU COME AT ANY POINT, EVER
CONSIDERED IN THE BACK OF YOUR
MINDS, A PARDON FOR ANY OF THE
PEOPLE YOU MENTIONED?
OR YOU WOULD WEIGH?
I THINK IS THAT AT ONE POINT HE
WOULDN'T CONSIDER IT UNTIL AFTER
IT ALL WORKED THROUGH.
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT
ON THAT AS FAR AS THE PARTIES
ARE CONCERNED.
YEAH, IT IS ABSOLUTE AND IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL THING.
I'VE HAD PEOPLE, JACK JOHNSON,
THE HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION OF THE
WORLD IN THE EARLY 1900s, AND,
HE WENT TO JAIL FOR, YOU KNOW,
NO REASON.
ANNE'S, SO MANY OTHER THINGS AND
ALICE JOHNSON IS ANOTHER GOOD
EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW, I REALLY FEEL GOOD
ABOUT GIVING IT, WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TREATED UNFAIRLY AND
ABUSED, ACTUALLY.
BUT, I HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT IT
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT'S GOING ON
NOW.
I MEAN, IT'S, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THERE'S A WHOLE NEW DAY
STARTING.
I THINK I MAY KNOW, I STILL USE
DRAIN THE SWAMP.
WE HAVE SOME VERY, VERY BAD
PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT.
THAT WOULD BE WILLING TO DIVERT
BAD THINGS AND FOR BAD REASONS.
SO, I DON'T MENTION, PARDON, BUT
I DON'T IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE FUTURE.
I JUST DON'T COMMENT ON IT.
SEE ONE MR. PRESIDENT, LAST
QUESTION ON THIS AND THAT I WANT
TO SWITCH TO 2020, IF I MAY.
COMEY.
McCABE.
COMEY SIGNED THE FIRST FISA
WARRANTS WHICH OPENS THE DOOR,
BARELY, ACCORDING TO NEWNESS AND
THE GRASSLEY GROUND THEM ALL,
THE BULK OF INFORMATION WAS
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR A
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
WE FOUND OUT FROM JOHN SOLOMON
LAST WEEK THAT HE HAD A
SPREADSHEET, EVEN IF YOU ARE IN
EARLY 2017, SAID 90% OF THIS
SAYING WAS FALSE GARBAGE AND NOT
TRUE.
COMEY SIGNED IT THOUGH AND THAT
ALLOWED A BACKDOOR FOR
CARTER PAGE TO SPY ON YOUR
CAMPAIGN, LATER TRANSITIONING TO
THE PRESIDENCY.
BUT McCABE, CHART, PAGE,
BRENNAN, KLAPPER, MAY BE
SOURCING OUT WHAT WOULD BE
ILLEGAL INTELLIGENCE GATHERING
GATHERING.
WE KNOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
THERE.
IS THERE ANY OF THESE NAMES --
WHAT YOU THINK OF THESE PEOPLE?
WHEN JANE'S COMEY SIGNED THE
FIRST PFIZER APPLICATION IN
OCTOBER 2016, WINTER TRUMP TOWER
IN JANUARY 2017, AND TOLD YOU IT
WAS UNVERIFIED, MONTHS EARLIER,
HE SWORE ON THAT APPLICATION,
THE PFIZER APPLICATION THAT WAS
VERIFIED, SO HE LIED.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THESE PEOPLE TODAY?
>> President Trump: WELL,
COMEY IS A LIAR AND A LEAKER AND
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS JUST
FOLLOW HIM ALONG AND SEE WHAT HE
SAID TO CONGRESS.
KLAPPER ENDS BRENNAN AND ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE, McCABE, THESE
ARE BAD PEOPLE.
MY OPINION, THEY ARE VERY BAD
PEOPLE.
THEY'VE BEEN VERY BAD FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THEY WERE --
I USED TO THINK INCOMPETENT BUT
THEY ARE REALLY I GUESS
COMPETENT AT OTHER THINGS AND
MAYBE BAD THINGS BUT WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
I MEAN, I GUESS A LOT OF THINGS
ARE COMING OUT AND IS GOING TO
BE VERY INTERESTING AND IT WILL
BE GREAT TO CLEAN UP A REAL BIG
MESS BECAUSE AGAIN, IT COULD
NEVER HAPPEN.
THIS COULD NEVER BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN AGAIN, SEAN.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
HAVE THE POWER TO LITERALLY
RELEASE THE PFIZER APPLICATION
AND THE THREE OH TWO'S AND THE
GANG OF INFORMATION AND YOU MADE
A DECISION TO HAND IT OVER TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND LET HIM DECIDE.
I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHY.
>> President Trump: WELL, WE
HAVE A VERY RESPECTED GENTLEMAN,
VERY HIGH QUALITY PERSON NAMED
WILLIAM BARR AND HE IS DOING --
I CAN TELL YOU HE'S WORKING SO
HARD AND RATHER THAN JUST DOING
A TOTAL RELEASE, I GAVE HIM HIS
TOTAL RELEASE, IN OTHER WORDS,'S
GOT EVERYTHING PAID ANYTHING HE
NEEDS, HE'S GOT IT.
HE IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES BUT HE'S GOT A
LOT OF VERY GOOD PEOPLE UNDER
HIM THAT I GUESS ARE INVOLVED
AND I GAVE THEM A TOTAL RELEASE
SO ALL OF IT HAS BEEN RELEASED
AND HE HAS ALL OF IT.
I'VE ALSO GIVEN HIM
AUTHORIZATION TO RELEASE IT TO
WHOEVER HE WANTS.
WHETHER IT'S HIS PEOPLE OR,
FRANKLY, PERHAPS PEOPLE LIKE
DEVIN NUNES WHO IS A STAR, WHAT
HE HAS DONE AND THE AMOUNT OF
SUFFERING THAT HE HAS GONE
THROUGH, YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DID
WITH HIM WHERE THEY TRIED TO
DRIVE HIM RIGHT OUT OF POLITICS
AND PROBABLY WORSE THAN THAT.
HE HAS DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
AND, SO MANY OTHERS.
I MEAN, THE JOB --
THEY ARE WARRIORS.
WE HAVE HAD, I'LL TELL YOU THE
GOOD SIDE OF ALL OF THIS IS THE
LEVEL OF INTELLIGENCE AND
STRENGTH AND GOODNESS THAT WE
HAVE HAD ON THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, A LOT OF THEM, NOT
EVERYBODY, OF COURSE, BUT WE
HAVE HAD TREMENDOUS, AND I SAY,
WHEN I SAY WE COME I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE COUNTRY VIA THE
COUNTRY HAS HAD TREMENDOUS
REPORTS FROM MEADOWS AND JORDAN
AND DEVIN NUNES AND SO MANY OF
THE NAMES THAT YOU SAW
YESTERDAY, PERFORM SO WELL.
I MEAN, THEY PERFORM SO WELL AND
THEY WORKED SO HARD BECAUSE THEY
SAW THIS WAS A SCAM.
THIS WAS AN ILLEGAL TAKEOVER, AS
YOU WOULD SAY IN THE BUSINESS
WORLD.
I MEAN, THIS WAS A COUP
ATTEMPTS.
IN MY OPINION.
AND THIS IS THE UNITED STATES.
ANNE'S, WE WOULDN'T STAND FOR IT
AND I WOULDN'T STAND FOR IT.
WE HAVE SOME VERY GREAT PEOPLE
BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME VERY BAD
PEOPLE.
AND I THINK WE CAUGHT THEM.
>> Sean: I BELIEVE, SIR, THAT
WE HAVE THE PREMIER LAWN
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE WORLD.
OUR FBI.
WE HAVE THE PRINTER INTELLIGENCE
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
THAT'S 99%.
1% OF THE TOP, THE ONES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ABUSING HARVEY IT
ALREADY, SO HOW CLOSELY ARE YOU
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE 2020
DEMOCRAT LED BY THE WAY SEEM
MOST INFLUENCED BY THE SQUAD
ENDS ALL OF THEM HAVING EVEN
ADOPTED SOME VERSION OF THE
INSANE NEW GREEN DEAL THAT WOULD
GET RID OF THE LIFE BLOOD OF OUR
ECONOMY?
>> President Trump: WELL, IT'S
VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T SEEN IT AT ALL FOR THE
LAST FOUR OR FIVE DAYS HERE THEY
ARE NOTCHING THAT THE DEMOCRATS
PAY THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
MUELLER AND HOW BAD HE
PERFORMED.
HOW BADLY HE PERFORMED.
AND THEN TALKED ABOUT EVERYTHING
THAT HAPPENED OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS BUT IN PARTICULAR,
YESTERDAY, YOU ARE NOT SAYING
MUCH ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS.
BUT, LOOK, YOU HAVE A FEW OF
THEM THAT ARE DOING A LITTLE BIT
BETTER THAN OTHERS.
IT'LL BE INTERESTING.
WHOEVER IT IS, I'M OKAY WITH IT.
WE HAVE THE BEST ECONOMY WE'VE
EVER HAD, AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
THE BEST STOCK MARKET NUMBERS
WE'VE EVER HAD IN THE BEST
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
IF WE LOOK AT WEREN'T 401(K)s,
IF YOU LOOK AT THE KIND OF MONEY
THAT PEOPLE ARE MAKING, NOT
TALKING ABOUT RICH PEOPLE OR JUS
TALKING ABOUT RICH PEOPLE OR JUT
TALKING ABOUT RICH PEOPLE OR JUR
TALKING ABOUT RICH PEOPLE OR JUC
TALKING ABOUT RICH PEOPLE OR JUH
PEOPLE, I'M TALKING ABOUT
EVERYBODY AND BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS WENT ON PROPORTIONALLY
MORE THAN ANYBODY YOU SAW THE
POLLS THAT JUST CAME OUT.
THINGS ARE DOING GREAT.
THE BEST UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS,
THE BEST EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, MORE PEOPLE
WORKING IN THE UNITED STATES
TODAY THAN AT ANY TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS, ESPECIALLY
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS, FOR
HISPANICS, FOR ASIANS, WOMEN ARE
ALMOST 70 YEARS, THE BEST
NUMBERS, AND SOON TO BE
HISTORIC, MEANING FOREVER.
MEANING FROM THE BEGINNING.
NO, I THINK WE ARE GOING TO BE
IN GREAT SHAPE.
THEN YOU HAVE THE AOC, I CAUGHT
A COLD AOC PLUS THREE.
>> Sean: WHO DO YOU THINK --
>> President Trump: THEY ARE
GOING TO HURT THE DEMOCRATS.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE WILL SEE.
BUT I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY WELL.
WE GO INTO THESE MASSIVE ARENAS
AND THEY ARE PACKED AND THERE'S
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN AN EMPTY SEAT.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO DO VERY
WELL.
>> Sean: THREE QUICK QUESTIONS
AND I'M GOING TO LET YOU GO
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN VERY
GENEROUS WITH YOUR TIME.
WHO DO YOU THINK WINDS AND WILL
YOU TELL US, AND IS THERE ONE OF
THE GROUP OF DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS
THAT YOU HOPE WINS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW YOU CAN BEAT THEM EASILY?
>> President Trump: WELL, YOU
KNOW, I COULD SAY THAT
OBVIOUSLY, THE TOP THREE OR FOUR
LOOK LIKE THEY ARE DOING BETTER
THAN THE REST.
SO, SLEEPY JOE IS OKAY BUT HE IS
FADING, THINK HE IS FADING FAST.
THE ONLY GOOD THING ABOUT
MUELLER IS IT MADE JOE BIDEN
LOOK LIKE YOUR DYNAMO.
SO, WHEN YOU WATCH MUELLER'S
PERFORMANCE YESTERDAY, I THINK
PROBABLY BIDEN IS THE ONE THAT
ASKED HIM TO GO ON.
SO, YOU HAVE HIM AND HE IS SORT
OF A LITTLE BIT LEADING AND THEN
YOU HAVE A WHOLE GROUP.
YOU HAVE ELIZABETH WARREN,
FORMALLY KNOWN AS POCAHONTAS.
I'M SURE THAT'LL COME OUT
BECAUSE THAT'S A TOUGH LEAD FOR
HER TO WITHSTAND, I BELIEVED IT,
BECAUSE HER WHOLE LIFE WAS A
FAKE.
SHE USED THAT VERY, VERY ADEPTLY
AND IT WAS NOT GOOD AND YOU HAVE
HARRIS AND BERNIE LOOKS LIKE HE
IS FADING, TO ME, BERNIE LOOKS
LIKE HE MISSED HIS TIME.
I THINK WHAT HILLARY DID A FEW
YEARS AGO WAS PRETTY TOUGH,
FRANKLY, FOR BERNIE.
BUT THAT WAS HIS TIME.
I DON'T THINK IT'S BERNIE'S
TIME.
I SEE HIM FLAILING.
HE IS FLAILING ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
HE'S GOING CRAZY.
I CALL HIM CRAZY BERNIE.
BUT THE FACT IS, I THINK THOSE
WOULD BE PROBABLY THE THREE OR
FOUR, MAY BE THERE IS ANOTHER
ONE OR TWO, YOU KNOW, I DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE ANYBODY ELSE
GAINING TRACTION.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, LAST
TWO QUESTIONS.
FIRST ONE IS ON BOTH IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA.
THEY HAVE RECENTLY FIRED TEST
MISSILES.
HERE'S MY QUESTION FOR YOU.
I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR MAINLY 25
YEARS.
I KNOW YOUR MIND-SET ON THIS
VERY WELL.
I SET IT ON THE AIR IN A MESSAGE
TO THE MAULERS THAT THEY BETTER
BE CAREFUL.
YOU WILL NOT PUT BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
YOU'RE PROBABLY GOING TO SHOW
SOME LEVEL OF PATIENCE BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY, IF THEY
FORCE YOU, I BELIEVE, KNOWING
YOU, I BELIEVE IS YOU WILL
DEVASTATE THEM.
AND NORTH KOREA, YOU HAVE GIVEN
THEM NOTHING.
PEOPLE CRITICIZE AND SAY CERTAIN
THINGS I BELIEVE ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
ONE, YOU WILL PUT NOBLES ON THE
GROUND.
YOU WILL NEVER TRY TO DRIVE A
DICTATOR LIKE CLINTON DID WITH
NORTH KOREA UNLIKE BIDEN OBAMA
DID WITH THE MOLARS.
I DO BELIEVE THAT IF PUSHED, THE
MILITARY MIGHT UNLEASH WOULD BE
MIGHTY AND WOULDN'T REQUIRE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND, AM I RIGHT?
>> President Trump: WELL, I
THINK THAT IN THE CASE OF IRAN,
I KNOW THAT BETTER EVEN THAN YOU
DO, I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
VERY WELL.
AND IN THE CASE OF NORTH KOREA,
I'M ACTUALLY GETTING ALONG VERY
WELL WITH HIM BUT WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THE SANCTIONS
ARE ON.
THE HOSTAGES ARE BACK, WE ARE
GETTING THE REMAINS BACK, THEY
HAVEN'T DONE NUCLEAR TESTING,
THEY REALLY HAVEN'T TESTED TO
MISSILES OTHER THAN, YOU KNOW,
SMALLER ONES.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT BLOT
TEST.
BUT I THINK WITH NORTH KOREA, WE
HAVE BEEN DOING VERY WELL HERE
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE.
WE HAVE A RELATIONSHIP,
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD NO
RELATIONSHIP.
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN AT WAR.
HAD HILLARY BEEN EXCELLENT ONE
IS ELECTION, HE WOULD'VE BEEN AT
WAR WITH NORTH KOREA.
I HAVE NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S WHERE IT WAS VERY
RAPIDLY.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS BUT I
THINK WHAT YOU SAID MIGHT BE
SOMEWHAT OF AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
STEALING LAST QUESTION BEARD I
HAVE SAID MANY TIMES IN THIS
KROGH PROGRAM, WELL, YOU'VE
GIVEN KIM JONG UN YOUR TIME HERE
WE HAVE REMAINS THAT, WE HAVE
HOSTAGES BACK, AND MISSILES
STOPPED UP UNTIL FAIRLY
RECENTLY.
YOU JUST GAVE TIME.
LET ME ASK --
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE IT'S NEW YORK
AND I KNOW A CITY THAT YOU
OBVIOUSLY LOVE A LOT.
YOU'VE SEEN ANY OF WATCH WITH
US, THESE POLICE OFFICERS WHO
ARE BEING POUNDED WITH WATER.
AND NOT REACTING.
TO ME, IF THIS CONTINUES, --
>> Sean: WELL, IT'S A BAD MAN.
PROBABLY THE WORST IN HISTORY.
IS ON A BAD JOB AND ALWAYS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
THE PEOPLE CAN EVEN BELIEVE IT.
HE'S A HORRIBLE MAYOR.
THE POLICEMAN AND WOMEN CANNOT
STAND HIM.
THEY DON'T RESPECT HIM, THEY
DON'T LIKE HIM, REMEMBER, THEY
TURNED THEIR BACK ON HIM A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WHEN HE GOT UPU
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WHEN HE GOT UPP
TO SPEAK ON EVERYBODY CHINA BACK
AND THEY KEPT AT THAT WAY.
THEY WANT TO DO IT SO BUT THEY
HAVE RESPECT FOR THE OFFICE, IF
NOT HIM.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS TRAGIC,
WATCHING THAT SCENE A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO WHEN I FIRST SAW IT.
I CAN BELIEVE IT.
I SAY, LET ME SEE THAT AGAIN.
I DON'T BELIEVE WHAT I'M SEEING.
AND I KNOW NEW YORK'S FINEST AND
I KNOW NEW YORK'S FINEST, IN
FACT, WE WERE IN TOUCH WITH HIM
TODAY.
THEY ARE DEVASTATED THAT
FRANKLY, THAT THAT COULD HAPPEN
AND ALSO THAT THOSE TWO OFFICERS
WOULD ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
THAT WAS A TERRIBLE THING.
>> Sean: WELL, EVERY SINGLE
ONE THAT WE HAVE ON VIDEO, I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ARRESTED.
MR. PRESIDENT, I WON'T TAKE